je ne sais pas ce que tu es en train de
faire
avant de plan dans une boîte
[Musique]
cercueil
ce n'est qu'une vieille boîte en pain
qui va avoir des ennuis à votre avis
fais-moi plaisir
être un peu optimiste
on en arrive pas là sans que les choses
aient commencé il y a longtemps
donc deux soldats et une infirmière se
retrouvèrent Amsterdam
nous avons conclu impact et avons juré
de nous protéger les uns les autres quoi
qu'il arrive
on se retrouve dans une situation où on
est accusé d'avoir tué quelqu'un ce qui
n'est pas vrai
vous avez fui les lieux avec Woodman le
tueur a pointé son arme sur nous on a
rien fait mais pourquoi pensez-vous
qu'il s'agit de nous je sais pas c'est
peut-être la description un médecin qui
cherche son œil de verre par terre avec
son avocat noir sa cour polaire j'ai
fait mes études à Colombia
à découvrir la vérité mon ami a été tué
parce qu'il avait vu quelque chose de
monstrueux
cette affaire se révèle bien plus
complexe que ce qu'on pensait
[Musique]
vous allez devoir m'obéir si vous voulez
qu'on s'en sorte j'ai déjà poignardé un
homme et une fois j'ai frappé une femme
avec une brique
c'est une longue histoire mais avec vous
deux ce sera un jeu d'enfant
nous vivons une époque dangereuse fais
bien attention
je vais faire quelque chose qui pourrait
mettre ma vie en danger
le coucou est dans le nid et le coucou
va être pris au piège
le coucou
[Musique]
c'est une des meilleures innovations qui
arrivent tout droit du rixe à supprime
toutes les douleurs avec moi on doit se
tourner vers l'alcool et la morphine et
ça peut mener à l'addiction oh ça va
vite c'est très efficace
[Musique]